ah remember the whoppers we had last
week so good I didn't have a whopper
chicken Sammy oh but we went to a
fast-food I'm trying to segue damn it
we're gonna watch a try not to laugh
video Family Guy funniest fast-food
chain jokes I'm excited to see what they
deemed funny to be in here well let's do
it
it's a focus group of Arby's executives
watching us eat 50 bucks says the fat
girl eats a third big beef and cheddar
who's on it I'll take that gun that
bread Kristen who that's what I know
right we're not we're not eating white
stuff hey you are something good just
look for the containers that say KFC on
them there's always something good in
there dude that's birds in there you're
eating another bird what that's bird
meat dude what know you're eating a bird
oh my god McDaniel's or a burger Queen
let's hop out no that's right we're on
television oh boy bopper so frustrating
we all know what we're talking about and
don't worry we're not gonna be one of
those cutesy couple morning our b.o.b it
stands for real Brian morning RB robot
Brian well much like every other Arby's
you are making me sick man know what
do you now I have to be even more
ridiculous to make up for what you guys
aren't doing silverware put them on so
usually you put a burger on a tray this
guy's putting a trained bird are you
kidding
god this is worse than having Ronald
McDonald for a father come back here
you're not going out with all that
makeup on dad upstairs
you're a McDonald not a [ __ ] Wow Joe
how'd you pull that off I put in a call
from the McDaniels payphone while you
guys were getting that nine piece
chicken mcfingers and those diet comics
and those fresh fries Oh oh boy in
French fries well my crisps nothing's
got that ring out yet that's why we
brought you to this fast-food roast beef
restaurant
yeah Angus big milk I'm sorry are you
here to poop something out yeah okay
this line is just for regular diners you
need to get in that line excuse me is
this the line for people who need to
poop something up I think this is just
the poop line Cheers
you know what restaurant we're talking
about because we're in the Coast Guard
and when you're ready grow a family
[Music]
oh dude you guys are gonna get so sick
[Music]
very salty you how'd you get the money
to limp this boat anyway
well I got a part-time job at Target
okay technically I work at the weird
in-store Pizza Hut the target in-store
Pizza Hut feed it to your fat kid while
you buy off-brand tennis shoes you know
you wrote all those Kentucky Fried
Chicken jingles I don't care for them
not after what happened to foghorn
leghorn I'll say I'll say son why don't
we got brewing in here I was walking by
when I picked up the smell of 11 herbs
and spice
I'm totally screwed
like those poor guys way to come up with
a new ad campaign for Subway hey I'm
Mike
I like sandwiches and people my own age
subway please don't think of pedophilia
[Music]
don't touch the fries in hog fat it
barely hurt spirits of those skin grafts
who would you like an apple pie with dad
would you like an apple pie with that
wait for the Bell ding fries it damn
[Music]
classic song I wish I had that as my
ringtone you should yeah for your
benefit a lot of these were just good
points there are times I was like yep
that uh that's pretty accurate
apparently a family guy really likes to
take jabs and RVs or just general roast
beef places I don't know well you like
maybe one of the writers got sick once
and now they forever hold a grudge
Arby's is like I see the menu and I buy
so much food and then I do get sick but
I always go back and at this I'm a I
actually liked about the commentary here
is that you do go back knowing what it
could do to you because of the food are
you sick because you over I had over
eating issues now you guys don't know
this I haven't made something like
public deal about it now I am a few
weeks ago I decided to go full-on
pescetarian which is greatly reduced my
fast food intake and I just have an
insanely unhealthy association with
faster like really bad and I was like
much heavier on the channel I had this
real problem where I couldn't sleep
unless I got fast food so there would be
plenty of times where I leave at like
3:00 in the morning
not my first place I lived at the second
place of paneling above the channel I
would leave at like 3:00 in the morning
and just go to Jack in the Box and order
a crap ton of food really unhealthy I
never thought about that
like I knew you but like unless I
specifically cooked something yeah it
was always that's why I never always
yeah so when we went to Burger King I
actually I got the impossible whopper
which by the way if you like impossible
burgers or you hung burgers whatever
that impossible whopper takes is the
delicious recipe I was like a fast food
connoisseur and that possible whopper
was amazing it was seriously great and
Del Taco has some great beyond tacos as
well um I would often throw up but still
keep cuz I was also like taking a lot of
medications okayed a bunch of cigarettes
eating a lot of faster wildly unhealthy
guy the next
so generally isn't good like it's not
good for you but it's just not good
that's so tasty though
yeah you always feel like such coupe
afterwards
yeah yeah I did poop a lot yeah hit me
one day is because growing up whenever
we got fast food when I was a kid we
wouldn't get like full meals than the
family you get a large frying you divide
it up with the kids not enough and then
you get no it's nothing and then we get
like burgers or to make salad sandwiches
you're dealing with Donald sandwich cut
it in half
it's I get like half a cent so always a
lot more I was wanting more so I think
but I started finally having enough to
really buy my own food I think I was
like make it up for some like childhood
Psychological Association I love how the
talk has turned into this this is the
most thought-provoking try not to laugh
that is really brought out a deeper
psychosis Reagan bizarre but another
good point family got peas up white poop
from the birds why is that me yeah are
there any other animals that do that I
know fish kind of do that but it's okay
cuz you know like they're number ones
and they're number twos I'll come out in
the same little lump yeah so you know I
know that birds do that and fish do that
and Greg does and a Greg does that but
are there any other animals that I can't
I can't think of any you know I I
haven't studied enough animal
feasibility I brought this up but I
really don't get the digestion and the
science behind hope it's also Pizza
Hut's at targets okay what are those
does anybody actually eat at those ends
I've never seen anybody it's not real
pizza okay it's not real I've never seen
anybody walk around in a target with a
piece of pizza all right I bought them
they're overpriced not filling but they
still taste good but the sock doesn't
taste like pizza though that's that's
the issue like the breadsticks taste
wait barely similar so it's the Pizza
Hut that doesn't taste like Pizza Hut
it's like the round pizzas pizzas are
generally round yeah but they're like
mini wrap you can't go like can I get a
large pizza with these toppings no you
get like a cheese
pepperoni and they're like just on an
oven to go and just hand you a box it's
like the ones that that's like the ones
that have I don't know if you guys out
in your States but there's some out here
that have like Taco Bell and Pizza
combined which is weird because it's a
full-on Taco Bell and not a complete
pizza by the same company or whatever I
also have like the Baja freshes and the
subways yeah it's weird cuz it's like
either/or they're never mixed true very
true well this has been a much more
thoughtful discussion than I realized
that's a poop you never know what you're
gonna get the real rejects I could have
easily just said huh almost laughed at
that moment but no it turned into this
there were a couple clips that really
liked the bird the birds got me wrong
alright guys well what's your favorite
fast food place leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell Joe yeah
take a listen be crazy switch channel
forgot I mention at the top what do you
do there
I do variety streaming with games and
also art cuz I'm an artist that does art
commissions on stream huh so go there
today see you guys
all right thanks crazy sauce